اريد ان اريك كل الاشياء التي تستطيع ان تفعلها مع ريموت
مبدئيا في البداية ريموت هو عبارة عن مجموعة كومبيترات صغيرة
كومبيتر الواحد هو البروجكت
لان انا اقول افتح لنيو بروجكت
هنا انا اسمي بروجكت اي حاجة
انا اسمي يوتيوب
لان هذا هيبقى اي حاجة اللي علاقة بيوتيوب تخصني
هتكون موجودة هنا
وانا اقفل البروجكت الاديم ده همسحه
لغاية لما الجديد ما يتعمل
ماذا نريد البداية من أول و جديد
طبعا هذا المفروض يأخذ وقت
لكي يجهز
وهو شغال
تعال نشوف هنا في settings
أنت المفروض عندك
الأجنس التي ستوصل بهم
أنا عملت login بتشاجبتي
بأحساب codex بتاعي
وبكيمي لم أقوم بعمل
لسه بcloud
يعني معناها أنا بوصل
codex ووصل كيمي
cli ووصل cloud كلهم موجودين هنا
البروجكت خلصت دعنا نرجع له تاني
دلوقتي بقى البروجكت دلوقتي بقى البروجكت دلوقتي
دلوقتي بقى البروجكت دلوقتي
لا يجب علينا أن نتركها حتى الآن
طبعاً سأحصل بسيرفرك
هذا السيرفر الذي سيتشارك عليه أكثر من كومبيوتر
لقد قمت بعمل واحد اسم يوتيوب
دعني أقوم بعمل واحد آخر
مثلاً يدير ماذا
هذا يدير يوتيوب لي
دعني أقوم بعمل واحد
الذي سيقوم بعمل لي موقع نت جديد
دعني أقوم بقول أننا نريد أن نبني
شيء مثلاً
الذي لديه علاقة بالموقع جديد
بشيء لديه علاقة بالكرساب
ننسمي مثلا اربك تيك
يعني ده كده كومبيتر كامل وده كومبيتر تاني
طيب ليه بنقول كومبيتر مختلف عن بعضه
عشان الحاجات اللي هورها لك دلوقتي
جوا الكومبيتر اللي اسمه يوتيوب اللي هو مشروع
أنا ممكن افتح اي تشات
ممكن افتح اكتر من تشات
وكل تشات المفلوض ان هي شغالة مع اي واحد من دول
او كلهم في نفس الوقت
اللي هو كودكس, كلود او كيمي
طبعا كل واحد فيهم بيغير المعلومات اللي نازلة هنا
اللي نوع الموديل، نوع الthinking، نوع الspeed
كلام اللي تبتلاقي موجود في Cloud Code Desktop و Codex Desktop
طيب في Codex انا اختار الموديل 5.6
والthinking انا اخلي X-High والSpeed خلا زي ما هي auto
والmode خلي code
طبعاً دي اللي skills اللي نزلة
فيه skill واحدة بس تنزلة اسمها browser ممكن ازاود skills
هنكلم عندي بعدين كمان شوية
دعنا نقوله "Hi, who are you" عشان نشوفها فعلاً متوصلة او لأ
ثاني، أنا هنا، جوا يوتيوب، ده يعتبر كومبيوتر كامل لواحده، أربك تيك، كومبيوتر تاني خالص، أنا في أربك تيك، هخش، خليها برضو، هاي، هو ويريو، تمام
جوا يوتيوب، معناها، طبعاً كلهم يكون شغلك نفس الوقت، أنا ممكن أفتح خمس، أفتح عدد لا نهائي، يعني ما فيش، ما فيش لمد بالنسبة لي حرفياً لعدد المشاريع اللي شغالة وعدد اللي، اللي، اللي تشات
تعالى نقوله هنا في اليوتيوب تعالى بنا نخش كلام طييل شوية أنا هقوله ايه؟
فقالك حاجة تخليها من هلو بالعربي
وبان احنا بنكلم بالعربي
انا عايز دلوقتي اديلك شوية لينكات يوتيوب
وعايزك تعملي صفحة كده عالنت
اخش عليها
الاقي فيها اليوتيوب فيديو
وترانسكريبشن بتاعته
فجهز كل حاجة وقالي امتى تكون جهز ان اديك لينكات اليوتيوب
فدلوقتي هو
لي بيقول ان هو كومبيتر
انت لو رحت اتكلمت مع تشجبتيه على النت
مش هيعمل لك هذا الكلام
انه سيبدأ يحاول نزل tools وكلام ده احنا فاهمين
بس مش هيبقى عنده القابلية نوى ينزل كل حاجة هو يقدر يعملها
يعني معاناها ما عندوش قدر نزل برامج من الالف للياء
لو انا شفت اول tool هو دخل على node modules بيشوف احنا موجودين بنعمل ايه
هو بيد او بتأكد احنا موجودين فين
للي بيقول ان مساحة فاضية وحما لها تطبيق خفيف من غير ده قدر
باختصارشة ديك جدا هو دلوقتي جوا جهاز computer linux
يقدر يعمل فيه كل اللي هو عاوزه
طيب مدام ده شغال تعال نقول ده بقى حاجة تانية
أريدكم أن تتكلموا بأي لغة أنا أتكلم بس من انجليزي عشان ننجز
طيب يبقى أنا قلت دي أي حاجة تخسر أربك تيك
يبقى أي حاجة خصوصة اربك تبقي هنا
تعالي نفتح شخص تاني هو شغال برضو
والمرة دي انا هقول له حاجة تاني خالص
انا هقول له
شوف بقى شغل اتقيل بقى
انو هاتي عندي كومبيتر كامل بتحكم فيه
كأنه عندي cloud code شغال
اي ان كان اللي شغال بس
مش شغال على
كومبيتر بدلها ده شغال live
طيب
انا عايز اعرف هوا هيفاهم ان هوا هينزل tools المطلوبة منه وللا لأ ان هوا عنده access تاني لبنتو كامل
فيقدر ينزل اي حاجة بتشتغل على linux
طيب الاخر اسم يوتيوب دلوقتي بيقولي خلاص انا عملت افتح صفحة الفيديوهات
لو انا دوست على open browser المفروض لو هيا نزلها هتظهر لي هنا
انا هقول له
يعني افتحتها مش تشتغل
اللي بس بفاهم احنا نتكلم ان احنا فاهمين يعني
أنه عنده القدرة أنه هو يشغل الحاجة على أي... يعني كأنه بدلاً من يكون فرسيل ومش فرسيل وكلام ده
إحنا نعمل development ناق دلوقتي وحتطلع على link "already accessed publicly" أي حد يقدر يوصله "public"
طيب تعال نشوف أين نفز الكلام؟ أهو الصفحة جاهزة
وال link موجود وطلع زارت هنا كمان
يبقى أنا أقدر أشوفها من حياتي من بروزر
الناس بتحب تبدي تعمل Vibe Coding
انا ممكن اقوله اعدل هنا وروح هنا
تعالا هنا والكلام اللي احنا بنقوله ده
ممكن اقوله على الفكرة حتة دي
تعالى نجرب
مالش دي؟ شو اللي بقى Vibe Coding بقى؟
طيب هو دلوقتي شغال المفروض ان ده
live interface
بس هل ده فعلا URL؟ اه طبعا
هل ده URL جاهز
على الدومين اللي انا عاملو يعني معنا ده بيحصل اوتوماتيك
اى سيرفر بتقولو رفعو
هو هقدر يرفع عدد لا نهائي بترفع على بورت
بيزود هو البورتات بس المهم اليوريل ده ديتو لأي حد
هيقدر يوصلو ولكن لازم يكون
معملو add في السيستم
ان هو يقدر لان كل ده معملو
behind the logon wall يعني مفعش حدي اكسس لما يكون عندو
اكسس على السيستم فانت تيجي هنا في sharing بتزاود اسم
شخص العايز يخش و ببقى انك اردت حملت
الجوجل فهو يخش يعمل
لوجن بجوجل دي قصة تانية وتفاصيل تانية المهم
عدل او ما عدل زي ما ترابطو
عدل حلو هل قادر اشوف
الهستري التعدلات المفروض لو كان في جيت ريبو
هو ما عمل هاش فانا ممكن اقولو قلتلك كلام ده كلو
في جيت make sure all our updates in the
جيت ريبو طبعا انت المفروض انت بتخلق
skills يعني انت بتعمل زي خلاك code
انا في الريموتر الشخصي بتاعي انا عندي scale اسمه vibe coder
بخليه يتعامل كانه vibe coder بحيث اللي بيشتغل معاه ما يستخدمش code خلص
انا لاتعرف اتعمل بcode هعملي هفتح الide بتاعي
و هلاقي هنا في الide كامل vs code نسخة code server طبعا نزلها
طبعا the extensions بتاعي انا كنت بنزلها
الكود بتاعي كله موجود هنا حرفيا كل حالة تخيلها موجودة
فده بقى هنا انت متخيل ان انا ممكن ارن اي حاجة خالص كلها في البروزر ممكن ارن اكتر حاجة تتخيلها في حياتك انا مش محتاج لابتوب تئيل تاني خالص كل حاجة هرن من بروزر العملية البرمجة كاملة متكاملة انا هعملها هنا من البروزر
الميسورة مصحوبة اذا قمت بتشغيلها ستجد انها فاضية
تخيل لو انا اعمل كل هذه الميسورة في نفس الوقت ستسحب الميسورة من عندي
بالفعل في هذه الحالة انظروا إلى ويبس طويلة واحدة وسحب ثلاثة جيجي يا ربي
يعني ربنا لن ندعلي نقول عليه ايه
بص ده سحب كمب 60 ميجا ممكن اعمل ران لخمس تلاف ديف سيرفر
اتخيل اي شخص في البرمجة يتحدث في 3 جيجا
ولو اريتك انا مش فاتقه تقريبا يغيب ديف سيرور واحد بس
على ويبس توم ربنا يعني
شارج بتي كودك 700 ميجا
وكلات كود برضه هتلاقي حاجة سيئ جدا
كلات كود بيكلم 2.50 عشان محاجة يعمل حاجة
اتخيل بقى لو كان شغال
الكمبيوتر يوس ومش كومبيوتر يوس والكلام ده
فا احنا دلوقتي انا هنا في البروزر بتاعي بقدر اعمل كل حاجة انا عايز اعملها
اريد ان افعلها
البروزر هانا ده الليف بروزر اللي بيوريك الحاجات اللي هو الاجينت بتاعك شغال عليها
هل نقدر بقى نتصفح الانترنت بجد ايدي ايدي ايدي دخلنا في حاجة جديدة
لو انا دوست على ده هيفتح لي حاجة اسمها الاجينت بروزر ودي حاجة بقى فوق الخال
دي شبيهة جدا من فكرة الكمبيوتر يوس بس احلى بكتير لان هي شغال 24 ساعة ومن غير ما الكمبيوتر بتاعي يكون شغال
يعني حرفيا هو دلوقتي فتح من عنده هو
كرووم على جهاز اللينكس بتاعه
أنا قلت لك
What is my IP
هيديني IP بتاع المفروض بتاع المانيا
لان انا رافع ده في المانيا
طبع هو كل شوية ممكن يداي
لانه هيعرف ان حضرتك bot
بس انت كل شوية بنفسك هتيجي
وتعمل الموضوع recapitulation
علشان يتأكد انك اتا مش bot
وهيعديها والدنيا هكون لطيفة
هي غالبان دي بتطلع لأول مرة
وانا اصلا دي فعلا امرها
اعرف ان انا في المانيا برغم ان انا في كندا ولكن الكمبيوتر بتاعي موجود على السيرفر بتاع هيتس نار اللي موجود في المانيا
انا هنا تعال دخلت في فصل كومنت النت سريع لان ده على حسب السيرفر اللي انا رافعه
فده ملوش اي علاقة بسرعة النت بتاعي انا يعني انت حرفيا ممكن تخلي الاجنت بتاعك يخوش يتصفح الانترنت كله بسرعة السيرفر اللي انت شغل عليه
اي vps تعمل عليه سيبقى سرعته علي جدا
انت بتعملش الرقم دم رغم انك بتعملش سريع جدا
بس عشان ده vps بيدفع فيه فلوس فالمفروض انه هو كويس
طبعا بفلوس قليلة يعني فالموضوع لطيف جدا
مش مجربة تصفح نت انا ممكن اقوله already استخدم
الskill بتاعت الbrowser وخش اعمل
حاجات كتير جدا انت اخذ بالك
انا ممكن اقوله خش يتصرف يعني ويعيش حياته بقى
عندما يقوم بعمل سيرش من نفسه يقوم بعمل سيرش بهذه الطريقة
يمكن أن يدخل على سوشيال ميديك
أنا خليته يدخل على سوشيال ميديا عندي
يدخل يحلل ويروح ويأتي
فالموضوع يدي قوة خارقة
طبعا الإيد اي قولناها
التربنر لو أنت عايز صفضل قعد هنا
وتدخل تراجع التربنر بتاعتك
مش محتاج حتى تفتح الإيد اي
دي من الخاصيات اللطيفة جدا
بتكون عايز تراجع حاجة سريعة
لا يجب أن تفتح IDE و ترى كيف تفعل
هذا هو فايل مانجر كامل يريك كل الحاجات
لا يجب أن تفتح IDE
وهذا يكون مفيد أكثر للناس
الذين لا يريدون أن يقوموا بوصول الكود
الذين يريدون أن يعملوا بيب كودينج
مثلا، لقد قمت بعمل فايل و يريدون أن يقوموا بنزيله
لنرى أربك تيك
قلت له أعملي
لا أعرف ماذا
هنا لا أعرف ماذا مطلوب منه
ولا أعرف ماذا مطلوب منه
أو أستطيع أن أقوم بنزيله
اكتشف لك ما تحتاجه
انا اقول لك اعيش حياتك ومع نفسه
انا ممكن اقفل ده خالص ماليش دعوة بي
واجي افتحهم الموبايلي ودي الحاجات التانية
ان الكل ده ممكن يتفتح من على الموبايلي
ان كله دعوة عبارة عن ايه PWA او Progressive Web App
فدي من الحاجات القوية جدا
انا شابه شغال مع نفسه ومش فارق مع ايا حاجة تكون شغالة
هذا مثل ما قمت ببناء الماركتين ويب سايب بتاع أربك تيك
طيب
ده بقى زي ما انت شايف تشات عادي جدا
مفيش اي حاجة كأنك شغال باجنت
بكل بساطة من الحاجات اللي هي زي كودكس وكلاد وكلام ده
القوة بقى ان انا ممكن احاول من كودكس وكلاد لكيمي في نفس التشات
لو حاسيت ان واحد فيهم اي كلام
يعني تعالى نقلب من
انا مش عامل تقريبا كلاد بس
ناو عملت كلاد لوجن وانا قلت الموضوع بسيط
كما قلت لك يمكنك أن تبني سكيل عادية جداً
ستنزل هنا في أجنس
تعال نقوله
فهو سيبني سكيل كاملة
و سيضعها
و سيعرف أنه يتعامل معها
هذا هو الموقع
لو عملت أحمد نوش الفيديو
لك مستنين أول فيديو
لو ديت أول فيديو
يجب أن ينزل كل الأدوات التي يحتاجها
من الآخر يستطيع أن يقوم بعمل أي شيء في الحياة
أي شيء تتخيلها يستطيع أن يقوم بعمله لأنه
هذا أجنت كامل متكامل
وهو كودكس أو كلاد أو كيمي أو أنتيجرافيدي أو أو أو
ويخدين الحاجة لنقصة في كل البرامج الثاني
الذي يحاولون أن يقوموا بعملها
لإخذته OpenAI
ولكن لا يستطيعون أن يقوموا بعملها بنفس القوة التي قمنا بعملها
لأنه عمل بفكرة العزل الكام لمشاريعك كل مشروع من مشاريعك هو عمارة عن كومبيوتر مختلف
دي ال اكسي كونتيينر كاملة يعني كومبيوتر لينكس كامل مختلف
فانت بتدي اللم كل الصلاحيات اللي هو محتاجها عشان يعيش حياته
فلما تدي له كل الصلاحيات وتدي له كل الأدوات وتدي له هاش كومبيوتر كامل
اللم مش عايزة أقول لك بيتحول لحاجة فضائية
يمكنه أن يقوم بعمل كل شيء يمكنه أن يتخيله وكل شيء لا يمكنه أن يتخيله من ألف للياء
هنا هناك الأشياء الصغيرة التي تبنيها سنة سنة بفكتر بروشك سيكريس لأنه إذا أردت أن أعطيه أكسس على حساباتي
أين ستسجلها؟
فنحن سنقوم بعمل طريقة جيدة بالنسبة كبيرة
يمكن أن تتحسن مع الوقت لأن السيكريس ستكون بعيدة عن الليل
حيث أنهم لا يرونها
بيبعارف ان هو ينادي عليها ازاي فاتبتعرف تسجيلها هنا
زي ما بتلاقيه في رسل او في الحاجات اللي انت مفروض اتعملت معا قبل كده
اللي هي فكرة ازاي بده environment secrets يعني
فالموضوع هنا كبرمجة سهلة جدا وكحد عايز يعمل اي حاجة اللي يعلقها بالcloud and codex
انا بستخدم remote بقالي دلوقتي شهرين في كل حاجة تتخيلها في الفيديوهات
بخليه يكلم مع الgraphics هي اميلي motion graphics
وعملت لنفسي مجموعة سكيليز تقوم بتعمل فيديو ايديتنج
وكل الفيديوهات اللي انا عم نتمه اخرى معمولة من عن طريق ريموت
وبعد ما بتعمل فيديو ايديتنج هو بيروح يرفحها بنفسه على اليوتيوب لان انا قدره ايديته اكسس اليوتيوب
زي فكرة كلاب بس الفكرة هنا انا مش شغال بكلاب بس انا شغال بيهم كلهم
وانا متديله اكسس لكمبيوتر كامل مش فارق معايا لو كومبيوتر حصل له اي حاجة لانه منعزل تماما
والموضوع آمن جدا جدا جدا